with top p schools offering online mba
programs in addition to the traditional
full-time format online mba has gained a
reputation both among students and
recruiters it is no longer considered as
a sub-standard option for pursuing an
mba in this video we will delve over the
intricate details of an online mba we
will touch upon what is online mba the
ideal student profile for an online mba
the benefits and drawbacks of an online
mba as well as how to choose the right
online mba program but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel
simplylearn and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from us
first of all let's talk about what are
online mba programs
online mba is not a new concept a few
years back before the inception of the
internet there were classic distance
learning programs but with the growth in
technology and connectivity the
education industry has spread its roots
virtually allowing students to pursue
their studies according to their
convenience
several studies have shown that the
growth in technology and resources has
prompted as many as 25 percent of mba
applicants worldwide to opt for an
online mba degree
next we will look into what is the ideal
student profile for an online mba
program if you have no prior working
experience and have just finished your
online mba certification then probably
you might be doomed to think that you'll
be able to change careers or waive the
certificate to reach the top of the
corporate hierarchy though a convenient
option the online mba program is not
ideal for beginners
you can miss out on the great learning
opportunities such as peer interactions
and class debates that happen in
conventional on-campus programs
although technology has enabled some of
these experiences through video
conferencing or chats the virtual world
is still yet to catch up with the real
world on the other hand if you are a
working professional who comes from a
few years of experience and is willing
to upskill yourself to understand the
nuts and bolts of business functions
than an mba could be a credible option
through this kind of immersive learning
experience you can excel in the company
that you're currently employed at or
even transition towards managerial
positions
let's talk about the structure and
curriculum of an online mba program
as the name suggests the main idea
behind online mba programs is to help
students obtain the degree at their
convenience it is usually designed to
match the on-campus curriculum as
closely as possible the course content
is delivered via online live lectures
recorded sessions and interactive video
conferences some of the top online
programs include career coaching
sessions and placement fairs as well
the durations for these programs are
quite flexible some universities offer
accelerated one-year programs while
others offer extended part-time tracks
spanning up to two to five years
considering that most students enrolled
in the course are working professionals
with heavy job commitments the
flexibility of academic scheduling is by
far the most important component of the
appeal around online mba programs
besides the advantages of pursuing an
mba degree at the time of your choice
and from the comfort of the couch there
are certainly other reasons to add the
attractiveness of online mba programs
also there are some disadvantages that
you should look into before taking these
programs hence let's delve into a few
pros and cons of an online mba program
first we will cover the pros of the
program the curriculum and faculty of
online programs can be compared to their
on-campus counterparts the very same
instructors teach the same curriculum as
on-campus courses hence the quality of
teaching and content delivery remains
consistent in online programs next one
is peer connectivity critiques of the
online program say that these programs
lose out on the on-campus experiences
such as face-to-face interactions with
professors and peers class debates and
placement fairs however most online
programs provided by reputed b schools
bridge their gap through meet your class
events career fairs one-to-one virtual
interactions and international projects
chat forums and online discussions
ensure that you have the advantages of
getting to know the global businesses
and business players through your
screens
the third benefit of an online mba is
that rote learning is not involved in it
most online courses have open books
tests and don't make students
learn by rote
furthermore these courses utilize
practical methods to test understanding
of business theory such as projects and
thorough assignments
another advantage of online mba is that
applicants who couldn't attend the
traditional full-time mba programs at
top-notch p-schools due to their high
tuition fees can participate in the
online courses of these schools for
lesser costs
also the students of an online mba
program continue to work which means
they don't lose out on their monthly
salary checks so there's definitely no
opportunity cost there's no relocation
and commuting costs no hostile and
stationary costs which means you will
end up saving a lot of time and money
on that note let's now understand a few
disadvantages of an online mba
although a few top online mba programs
have created interactive platforms and
chat rooms to overcome the communication
gap however they are not as effective as
on-campus experiences
you will miss out on the live class
experiences on on-campus events alumni
networking opportunities and
peer-to-peer camaraderie in addition to
that the career support provided by
online mba programs is yet to reach
efficiency as of its counterpart on
campus programs the next major demerit
of an online mba program is that they
don't qualify for student visa this
leads to trouble for students who want
to avail international post-study work
permits this team merit makes these
programs vulnerable for students seeking
an international exposure
however the ideal student profile for
these courses is someone with two to six
years of professional experience hence
these team merits are totally negligible
online mba can prove a magnificent asset
to working professionals helping them
grow in their own organizations or on a
similar platform with the existing
networks to bank upon since the covet
pandemic the whole world has gravitated
towards virtual solutions and the
education industry is no exception to
that the on-campus programs are now
operational in a blended mode of online
and offline lecture delivery
this has led to tremendous growth in the
value of accredited online mba programs
the recruiters are now open and
receptive to the capabilities of online
mba grads especially if the online mba
is done from reputed b schools with amba
or aacsb
accreditation so before choosing any
online mba program conduct thorough
research about available online programs
and their accreditations
you can look into the rankings given by
famous publications such as financial
times and qs
these publications publish an annual
ranking of business schools with the
finest online mba programs across the
globe a thorough analysis of factors
such as course alumni performances
available specializations eligibility
criteria and most importantly your
budget will land you with the best
suited mba program
the pgdm program curated by simplylearn
in collaboration with one of the leading
indian b school jackson can provide you
with extensive managerial learnings
this program has been ranked amongst the
top 100 global mba programs by qs and is
accredited by aacsb and aicte
it is one of the five percent top
international online mba programs with
this elite dual accreditation
so go ahead and start exploring with
that being said can you all share your
honest opinion about which mba program
do you believe is better make sure to
drop your thoughts in the comment
section below this will allow us to
learn about your expectations for online
mba programs and even put some of them
into action that's all we have for today
i hope these tips are helpful to all of
you out there and i wish you all the
very best
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here